flex in this season tonight making his
25th start he's having one of the best
months of august of any american league
starting pitcher
yeah when chris flexon is the best he is
focused on executing his pitches uh you
know when he's beating his chest when
he's just a little bit angry uh that's
when he's good the astros have two
runners on for the big man jordan
alvarez
that ball drilled into center field back
goes kellnick still going back turns
around it's off his glove and off the
wall brantley got a late start he's
still being waved around the throw home
will not be in time jordan alvarez heads
into second base with no one covering
and the astros in front one to nothing
bases are now loaded with astros and one
out here in the first inning now tucker
will have to battle down 0-2
tucker fly ball and the change-up is it
deep enough correa is the runner on
third kellnick lines it up correa is
going to try and score here comes the
throw carlos safe at home plate with a
head first slide sacrifice fly by tucker
makes it a two-nothing game well you can
see the roller coaster for flex in there
luis garcia on the mound for the astros
tonight 10-6
3.21 era in 24 games 22 starts 123 in
the third innings 98 hits 37 walks 144
strikeouts league batting 217 against
garcia won his last start tuesday
against kansas city lead off man aboard
for mitch haniker
ground ball towards shortstop correa to
altuve on two base turn in time for the
double play
big double play on a 2-0 pitch from
louise garcia and that wipes out the
opening hit by jp crawford two up two
down here is jose marmaleos swing in a
well hit ball deep to right field line
shot and goodbye baseball welcome back
jose marmaleos a line drive missile into
the lower deck in right field
his first
hit on his return from tacoma is his
fourth home run overall in the season he
hit 23 of them down at tacoma jose
marmaleo's getting the mariners on the
board here in the bottom of the second
it's now the astros ii
and the mariners won and that thing was
shot out of a cannon holy smokes welcome
back jose nice catch kiddo the focus and
the concentration in right field to make
that catch though
she's walking home with one heck of a
souvenir kalnik leads off the bottom of
the third
and he got him strike three took
something off really pulled the string
there jared kellneck not able to keep
his bat in the zone long enough luis
garcia's got some filthy stuff jp
crawford singled his first time up
strike three got him on the changeup
crawford goes down and it's a one two
three inning for garcia marmaleo's a
chance to tie or give the mariners the
lead
broke a bat at the shortstop correa in
the shift and mar malays retired for the
final out of the inning so garcia
strands two runners two out traffic for
flex and now facing kyle tucker who
roped a double against him earlier also
drove in a run on a sac fly a 1-1 pitch
swinging a ground ball right side off to
his right is toro he's got it to throw
back to first and it's in time to get
tucker and chris flexon gets out of
trouble tight run at third well now
kalnik just needs a healthy fly ball to
tie this one up
this one popped high in the air to
center field myers coming in still
coming in not sure it's deep enough
terence will be held
and the throw comes in wide here's tom
murphy
he got him beautiful swing and miss it
was nicely done by luis garcia showing
some poison coming back
big strikeout for luis garcia getting
murphy after the shallow fly ball by
kelvin now second straight ending the
mariners have had runners parked on the
corners mitch haniger trying
to at least tie this game up in the
fifth
got him
big strikeout for luis garcia
works around a runner on third base and
nobody out to preserve the astros 2-1
lead after five the left miss diaz
leading off for the astros here
slowly hit myers good speed seeger's
gonna have to hurry out at first base
jake myers just barely thrown out good
play
by kyle seeger for out number two
good play by the veteran third baseman
not going with the bare hand using the
glove to secure that catch nobody out
first and second mariners down a run
toro a chance to tie this one up
on the ground raley has it to second for
one altuve steps on the bag turns the
double play
big double play on the comebacker to
brooks raleigh third double play toro's
hit into this season and the astros
needed that one dylan moore
is on the back for jose marmaleo's a
little history between these two
that's right
might be why marmalajos is
taking a seat for dylan moore last time
these guys matched up it was a big swing
from dylan moore
dylan the high left out to left center
field he tagged it again
dylan moore a two-run pitch hit go ahead
home run
against a familiar foe
nightmares
three two mariners tying run on second
base with nobody out and kyle tucker the
batter
he does pull it that's a base hit into
right field around third comes julie
guriel he's gonna score this game tied
up at three rbi single kyle tucker now
it's jake myers he's one for three
tonight
hit sharply that's a base hit tucker had
to hold up and he will be waved around
and no throw astros take the lead four
to three how does dylan moore not come
up firing and anticipate a play
incredible omar lopez with an aggressive
send after kyle tucker stopped in
between second and third and there was
not even a play made astros lead 4-3
luis terrence leads it off for the
mariners
a lead-off walk
[Applause]
mariners bring the winning run to the
plate
presley will face jared kellnick
got him
frozen with the breaking ball at the
knees ryan presley back from down three
and one
strikes out jared kellnick third time he
is struck out tonight just a perfectly
placed pitch now cal raleigh will bat
pinch hitter here for tom murphy
ball on the center field playable jake
myers makes the call puts it away out
number two
crawford last hope for the mariners
on the ground playable to second they go
for the force out and that is the ball
game